مروحيات روسية
تنطلق من بيلاروسيا
وتهاجم مطارا عسكريا قرب كييف،
واستهداف للعديد من المطارات الأوكرانية
في أقل من يوم واحد على الغزو...
الطرقات ازدحمت بالفارين من رعب الحرب،
الناس تهافتوا إلى محطات الوقود.
وازدحموا أمام الصرفات الآلية
لسحب أموالهم.
الكل يستعد لأيام هي الأصعب
في حياة الشعب الأوكراني.
١٠٠ألف لاجئ من دو نباس فقط
دخلوا روسيا هربا من الموت
بفعل التصعيد العسكري،
السلطات الروسية تقول أن بين اللاجئين
أكثر من ٣١ألف طفل،
ستقدم روسيا لهم إمكانية إكمال تعليمهم في مدارسها
ريثما يعودون إلى ديارهم بعد انتهاء العمليات العسكرية،
وتواصل كثيف لتدفق اللاجئين إلى روسيا
توقف للطيران المدني في جنوب روسيا
وفي عموم أوكرانيا بسبب الأوضاع..
الطائرات المدنية توقفت والمطارات أغلقت.
مئات العالقين فقدوا وجهتهم.
يا الإلاهي ما هذا الذي يحدث
وأي جنون هذا يقوله الأوكرانيون
ولسان حال العالقين عن السفر يقول:
(لا أحد يقول لنا ما يحصل،
أو ما سيحصل بطائراتنا وأين نذهب،
ليس لدينا مكان نذهب إليه، لا أحد يجيب علينا، )..
الأمن الفيدرالي الروسي يتحدث رسميا
أن ٤٦ فردا من حرس الحدود الأوكراني
تركوا مواقعهم وتوجهوا إلى روسيا...
(موجة نزوح للسكان وهروب كبير للجنود).
يقول الخبراء أن العظماء لا يدخلون حربا
بين بعضهم البعض،
وهذا هو حال أمريكا أمام الغزو الروسي،
لأن أي حرب عالمية لا يكسبها أحد
بل الكل سيخسر.. لكن الحروب ما دون ذلك
(ممكنة وموجودة)
وسباق التسلح مشروع ..
كل الخيارات الآن لازالت مطروحة
ويظل السؤال الآن هل تشعل أوكرانيا
شرارة حرب عالمية ثالثة؟
الجيش الأوكراني يتهم صراحة
جيش بيلاروسيا بالتوغل في المحور الشمالي
للبلاد محور خار كيف،
المعارك مشتعلة في شمال شبه جزيرة القرم،
(تهديد ووعيد لبوتين بعد العملية العسكرية في أوكرانيا)
من سيتدخل سيرى مالم يره في تاريخه
وسيؤدي إلى نتائج لا تتخيلونها
(في رسالة غير مباشرة إلى أمريكا)...
خلاصة كلام بوتين لتبرير خطوة الغزو هي أن:
روسيا اتخذت جميع الخيارات من ٣٠ عاما،
قبل التحرك للحرب  بالمفاوضات
والسبل الديبلوماسية والاقناع مع حلف الناتو
لعدم التوسع شرقا، لكن روسيا
لاقت الكذب والخداع، لا يمكن لروسيا
أن تبقى مكتوفة الأيدي وهي ترى كيف
أن أمنها يتعرض للخطر...
(أبرز مناطق  القصف و الانفجارات)
انفجارات في مناطق مختلفة من أوكرانيا،
استهدفت روسيا مطارات ومقار عسكرية في العاصمة
كييف بصواريخ كروز وصواريخ بالستية.
وانفجارات كبيرة في مدينة كراماتورسك شرقي أوكرانيا..
وسماع انفجار كبير ومدوي في خار كيف
ثاني أكبر المدن الأوكرانية هز المنطقة في ساعات الفجر الأولى..
صواريخ ضربت أيضا مدينة دنيبرو
وسط البلاد وفق مسؤولين أوكرانيين،
أما في الجنوب فنزلت قوات روسية
في مدينة أوديسا الساحلية على البحر الأسود.
مدفعيات ثقيلة تقصف أوكرانيا
من الحدود الروسية والبيلاروسية،
وما لا يقل عن ١٠هجمات شنت معظمها
على مناطق أوكرانيا الشرقية الجنوبية
وسط استهداف العديد من الطائرات للمطارات الأوكرانية
(ردود الفعل تتوالى)
برنامج الغذاء العالمي:
الحرب كارثة مطلقة ونتوقع ارتفاع أسعار الغذاء
والوقود والشحن...
أول ظهور لرئيس أوكرانيا منذ بدء عملية
روسيا العسكرية على أوكرانيا.
مطالبا الشعب بعدم الفزع وأن يبقوا في منازلهم.
ومعلنا بدأ تنفيذ أعراف الحروب...
(  حيث دخلت حالة الطوارئ لمدة 30 يوما
في جميع أرجاء البلاد، ما عدا المنطقتين الانفصاليتين،
حيز التنفيذ في منتصف ليل الأربعاء
صباح الخميس بالتوقيت المحلي.
وتشمل حالة الطوارئ فحصا شخصيا للوثائق،
ومنع جنود الاحتياط العسكريين من مغادرة البلاد،
ومنح الحكومة سلطة فرض حظر تجول)
بينما قال قائد الجيش الأوكراني،
ميجور جنرال فاليري زالوجني، إنه تلقى أوامر
من زيلينسكي بإلحاق أقصى الخسائر
بروسيا "المعتدية".
ليصرح الجيش الأوكراني إنه قتل
حوالي 50 "محتلا" روسيا،
لكن لم يتحقق من ذلك العدد من مصدر آخر.
(العقوبات على روسيا)،
الجانب الروسي:
(ليس هناك أي شك أن ردنا على هذه العقوبات
سيكون قويا. ليس مماثلا بالضبط لكنه سيكون مدروسا
وحساسا  بالنسبة للجانب الأمريكي)
في المقابل.
بايدن يقر بأن العقوبات الأمريكية
ستضرب كذلك اقتصاد بلاده...
العقوبات الأمريكية الجديدة شملت
عقوبات ضد مصرفي
(promsvyazBank, VEB Bank)
وشملت الدين السيادي الروسي
وشملت ٥أفراد روس مع عائلاتهم
وشملت مشروع السيل الشمالي2
بينما العقوبات الأوروبية استهدفت
٢٧ شخصية
ومنظمة روسية بينها مصارف
واستهدفت ٣٥١ عضوا من مجلس الدوما الروسي
(منع الاتحاد الأوروبي من تداول السندات الروسية)
أبرز الردود جاء من بريطانيا...
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بوريس جونسن:
أستغرب كيف أن بوتين لم يفكر بأن غزوه لأوكرانيا
سيجعل روسيا بلدا منبوذا.
وقال جونسن : هناك دولة تحاول إعادة رسم الحدود
في القارة الأوروبية عن طريق سفك الدماء.
وأضاف: دعوت لاجتماع لقادة الناتو غدا
وحذرت من أنه سيكون لهذا الغزو تداعيات عالمية.
وأردف جونسون : سنواصل الضغط على روسيا
لإخراجها من النظام المالي العالمي أولا بأول.
وأضاف جونسن بعضا من التصريحات
النارية إليكم نصوصها
: الأوليغارش الروس لن يجدوا مكانا للاختباء
في لندن.
: سنفرض حظرا على تصدير السلع ذات
الاستخدام المزدوج لروسيا وسنعطل قدراتها
لسنوات قادمة.
: سنعلن حزمة عقوبات غير مسبوقة
لعزل البنوك الروسية عن النظام المالي
البريطاني
: أدعم بقوة قرار برلين
بتجميد خط نقل الغاز نوردستريم 2.
علينا التصدي لهذه المغامرة البربرية
لبوتين التي يجب أن تقوده إلى الفشل.
الأخبار تتوالى والتطورات مستمرة
بشأن الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا،
بانتظار رد حلفاء كييف والعقوبات التي
قد تغير مجرى الأزمة إذا ما نفذت